if you know that you live on cheap and
this is a big one if you know it doesn't
cost you much to live
your risk tolerance goes up because you
don't have other to worry about
real cost of the that you can't
afford or shouldn't be affording right
now is that you're paying for the car
but you're sacrificing your dreams you
become less dangerous
because it's very hard to fight someone
who has nothing to lose
and it's very hard to find someone
who can live on nothing
if we had to pick between living on ten
thousand dollars a month and making ten
thousand dollars a month or living on
fifteen hundred dollars a month and then
spending the spread if you spend five
thousand dollars a month three thousand
dollars a month two thousand dollars a
month on your education so that you can
increase your earning capacity
it's hard to be stopped